[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRITHPAL BHOGILL: Good
morning, everybody.
Thanks for taking the time
to come to this session.
I know it's the last
day of the conference.
Hopefully you guys had
an amazing conference.
So today, we will talk about
how do customers really
accelerate their API for
strategy and leverage
enterprise and apps and the
data, which is logged in there.
How do you really
unlock that value
and bring it to your customers?
So I am Prithpal Bhogill.
I'm part of the Apigee Product
Team within Google Cloud.
And then I'm also going to
be joined with my co-speaker,
Pratik from Informatica.
So let's get started.
Today, many, many
enterprises are at some point
of time in the digital journey.
And it's really all about
taking the awesome amount
of data that they have, which
sometimes is locked in silos,
but unlock all of them
as APIs to deliver
these connected experiences.
That has pretty much
become the hallmark
of any successful
digital company.
As they're beginning to
express more and more
of that capability
through APIs, it
becomes very important to take
an outside-in perspective.
And that's exactly what we mean
by the digital value chain.
When we talk to
many customers, it's
pretty obvious they have a lot
of capabilities, some of them
which are also enabled an APIs.
But it's not all about having
N number of APIs or services.
It's about how
carefully you curate
those APIs to deliver the
right kind of experience
to the end user.
The app developer plays
a very important role
in taking those experiences
and [INAUDIBLE] them
up so that the end
user essentially
has the experience of
what they need to see.
That is what we call as
the outside-in perspective.
And in our experience, we have
seen successful API programs
really satisfy all the aspects
of the data value chain.
Apigee happens to
power successfully
be a program for
many, many customers,
and we are really
thankful for having
an opportunity to serve them.
As you may see,
we have customers
across all different verticals,
Fortune 100, 500, 1,000, SMBs.
All kinds of shapes and sizes.
And they have come to
rely on our capabilities
to be able to run their
programs successfully.
It turns out Apigee has just the
right API management platform.
So let's spend a
few minutes out here
thinking about what's
really required
to power an API program.
Of course, there's the
secure and scalable runtime,
which you need to
be able to power
and manage your API traffic.
But the important set of
vertical capabilities,
which layer on top of that.
So as an example,
the mediation engine
gives you all the
bells and whistles,
such as I need to secure
all my API traffic.
Awesome, we have
a policy for that.
You drop it in, and
suddenly all the API traffic
is secured using OAuth.
Again, you have some
traffic management policies,
such as controlling
spikes in traffic
or perhaps you want to
enforce business quotes.
All those set of
capabilities are provided
by the mediation engine.
As you start to move
up in the layer,
it becomes very
important for you,
as a customer, to have
the end-to-end visibility
across the entire API
program, whether that means
operational metrics
or keeping track
of how your API your program is
doing, so developer engagement
metrics.
Once we have APIs,
are developers
even building some apps and
driving traffic against them?
And last, but not the least--
this happens to be the most
important part of the platform--
how do you really engage
with application developers?
OK, how many application
developers in the audience
out here?
Just a quick show of hands.
OK, so what we have
seen is today--
I'll just do a very
simple analogy.
If you have a mobile app that
you're using on your phone,
and it takes you more
than four seconds for you
to navigate from one
screen to the other,
chances are you're going to
go and download another app
from the app store, right?
APIs are at that level today.
If you do not make it
easy for your developers,
for the application
developers, to consume
the API without any friction
and if the APIs are not
clean and simple
to understand, they
are going to move to a
different API provider, OK?
So it's very important to
provide a rich catalog of APIs
to the developer portal with
complete API documentation,
so it is very, very easy
for them to adopt the API.
So Apigee's API management
platform offers exactly that.
And artificial intelligence
and machine learning
is actually built into
the core of the platform.
Many of our customers
have actually
used the API and
its capabilities
for a period of time,
and they've really
gotten some good success
out of it, especially
in keeping track
of the API program.
Although, a lot of
those metrics have
been more around
trending parts of what
really happened in the
last hour or last week.
What we are announcing
today is the beta
of the Apigee-- the API
monitoring solution.
And this really brings the
real-time contextual API
monitoring for APIs
integrated into the platform.
It helps you better
manage your API SLAs
and give you the
ability to diagnose
all your issues in a much
shorter period of time.
More importantly, we
have seen many customers
who expressed the need that in
order for me to diagnose what's
really happening
with my APIs, I have
to correlate many things
across a few different tools,
such as I want to be able to see
what's happening with my logs.
And I want to see what my
alerts are being fired.
And I really want to be able to
correlate the entire sequence.
Apigee's monitoring actually
gives the ability to,
just within a few
clicks, have that context
at your fingertips.
And we don't want you to
take our word for this.
One of our key
customers, Bazaarvoice,
has been an early adopter of
the Apigee-- the API monitoring
solution.
And they are using this to
be able to proactively detect
and fix issues, even if it
happens to be on the target
backends, so that they
can manage the customer's
SLAs better.
We will be turning
on this feature
for a lot of our customers
over the next 30 days.
So really, really, really proud
to announce this capability.
Now, let's shift back to how do
you really accelerate your API
first strategy.
And what's really in that?
From our experience, we have
seen three high level things,
which take the
most pain in terms
of trying to become digital.
The first one is obviously
how do I easily and securely
connect to cloud services,
fast applications,
and in many cases, on-premise
applications as well?
The second piece that
becomes really important,
once you've done that, how do
I easily take those assets,
turn them into highly
curated APIs that can
deliver the right experience?
And more importantly, do
not forget the application
developer.
You want to ensure that the
application developer has
the right set of tools,
modular capabilities,
so they can reuse those assets
and turn out and churn out
API much faster.
So for that, let's
kind of break down
the anatomy of how do you
really access a cloud service.
It turns out there are a
set of repeatable steps
that has to be done
over and over again.
So let's try and just walk
through them very quickly.
So let's say I decide I need
to access some kind of a cloud
service.
But first, as an
API developer, I
have to figure out where
do I store the credentials
with that service.
Could be a service
account, could be just
a simple username, password.
I need a secure
mechanism to persist it.
Secondly, once they
have that, then I
need to go talk to
a token endpoint,
passing in those credentials,
so I can actually
get a token to that service.
Then I have the same issue that
I need to go manage the token,
persist it, and also worry about
the exploration and refresh
cycles.
But once I've done
that, finally, I
can go call my cloud service.
And although that's
a set of things
which you have to do
to access a service,
we feel it's very error prone.
If you have one
API developer who's
trying to do that to
access the service
and suddenly they need
to scale to provide that
to many different
services, it just
becomes extremely repetitive.
It's time consuming.
It's not easy to have the API
developer wire those things
over and over again.
And more importantly,
the [INAUDIBLE] steps
tend to build up over time and
causes a loss in productivity.
The other thing
we constantly hear
is administrators are not
very comfortable letting
developers manage and
deal with credentials.
OK, they want to have the
right separation of concerns.
They want to be able to
have designated roles
who can manage credentials, and
more importantly, have the API
developers go off and do their
stuff, which is go access
those APIs or services and
build some nice experiences.
So let's see how we
can get around this.
How many Apigee Edge users
in the audience today?
How many have actually touched
the Apigee Edge platform?
OK, a few of them.
So as you may have come to
know, Apigee is very powerful
and comprehensive full lifecycle
API management platform.
And it offers you
two big choices.
You can use a
configuration-based option,
which means you have 30
different out-of-the-box policy
that you can use to secure,
to provide traffic management,
do some mediation,
transformation, et cetera,
right?
And that's great.
And using some of
those policies,
you can do those four steps
we just spoke about, right?
Token, get your credentials,
finally access the service.
Or you can use some of the
out-of-the-box coding policies
that we have.
And we support different
kinds of languages--
Java, JavaScript, Node,
Python, et cetera.
However, it still requires you
to do those four steps that you
just reviewed manually.
Today, we're introducing the
new Apigee extensions capability
as beta.
And we're delighted to
have this capability be
available to our customers over
the course of the next 30 days.
Now, what does extensions
really bring into the mix?
It brings three
high level things.
It brings a modular
and secure way
of connecting to
your cloud services.
And it gives
developers the ability
to use simple policies, which
we'll show you in a demo
here very quickly, to call and
invoke those specific services.
So as part of this
announcement, we are rolling out
eight different GCP extensions;
extension of GCP services;
a brand new extensions
management user interface,
so org admins can actually go
and configure those extensions;
and in true Apigee fashion,
an extension Management API,
so you can use those APIs
to be able to communicate
with the platform if you don't
want to use our user interface.
So here are the
eight new extensions
that we are rolling out today.
It's available as beta.
So I'm not going to
go through the list,
but we'll actually see a live
demo here very, very soon.
In order for me to actually
show you something useful,
let's imagine a use case.
We're going to do
a live demo here.
So in this case, how
many of-- out here
ever have to worry about
data loss from enterprise?
Anyone?
Come on.
Some of you folks are being shy.
All right, data
security is a big issue.
In this quick example, I want
to show you how simple and easy
it is for an Apigee
API developer now,
using Apigee extensions, to be
able to interact with a data
loss prevention API,
which is a service
that Google Cloud
Platform provides, OK?
So in this case, let's
take a quick peek at how
we would go about doing that.
Going to switch onto
my demo mode here.
OK, that works.
Awesome.
Hopefully the demo
gods are with us today,
and the wifi works great.
So one of the first things
we're going to do out here
is very quickly go and look at
the new extensions interface.
So I'm logged into
an Apigee Edge org.
And I can come to this
extensions page under Admin
and add any extension.
So you can see some
of the extensions
that we were
talking about here--
the Cloud Vision API, Data
Loss Prevention, Firestore,
Stackdriver, Pub/Sub,
so on, and so forth.
The idea is we are rolling
out this extension,
and we'll continue to
add more down the road,
but these are much more built
towards API-centric use cases,
OK?
So once I come out
here, I can just
select that
particular extension,
give it a name and description.
And once you do that,
you have the extension
listed in your organization.
So let me just, for the
purpose of this demo,
use an existing
extension out here.
The extension has-- it can be
deployed across multiple Apigee
Edge environments.
So in this case, I have
deployed this thing for test.
And really, the interface
mechanism is super simple.
In this case, you take
the service account
that you have from within the
Google Cloud Platform project,
you supply the
service credential
when you're deploying
this specific extension,
and once you save it,
it will automatically
persist the credentials
securely and give you a checksum
out here, right?
So separation of concerns from a
governance perspective, the org
or the extension admin
can come and do this, OK?
And out here, you
will see logs as
to when that's specific
extension is communicating
with a service in
the background.
Great.
Now, once I've done that, that's
the one-time configuration
that I have to do to
enable that extension.
As an API developer my job
becomes extremely simple.
So let's take a look
at this DLP sample.
In this simple API proxy,
remember, I still have to go--
if I'm not getting
extensions, go
and do those four different
steps we spoke about, right?
But using extensions,
the credential management
overhead is not my issue.
So I go out here as
an API developer.
I can add a step out here.
Click a simple Extension
Callout policy,
select any extension that I've
configured-- in this case,
DLP--
and it will
automatically populate
the right kind of action.
So in this case, we have three
actions defined out here,
which are obviously reflective
of what the Data Loss
Prevention API exhibits,
which is deidentifyWithMask,
WithType, or redact the image.
So I just happen to use
the deidentifyWithMask.
And you can see I've already
configured this out here.
I'm sorry. deidentifyWithType,
specify the action out here,
and that's it.
At this point in
time, let's go take
this thing for a quick test.
So I'm using Postman out here.
And I've made some
changes in my API proxy
so that I will compare
the value of the header.
And if it is unsafe, I will
not involve the Data Loss
Prevention API.
Again, you can write this
thing whichever you want to.
So in this case, here
is the simple request,
which is going in.
Let's hit Send.
And when I do that,
you should see the data
is just passing through
as is, not really ideal.
So now, let's go out
here really quickly
and change this to Safe Mode.
And when I do that and
now send it through,
you can see that
the data has already
been masked automatically by
the Data Loss Prevention API.
Very simple example
of how you can
use a new connector, the
new extension mechanism
to be able to leverage
any kind of service
in a very, very module way.
OK, so let's wrap this
one up real quick.
So we just went through
the branding extensions
capabilities.
It's beta today.
It will be available
for customers
as we start to roll them
out in the next 30 days.
But we are going to be adding
a lot more capabilities.
We're going to be building
more extensions to existing GCP
services and to other providers.
And more importantly,
we will also
be building and rolling
out the same extensions
framework to our
customers, so you
can build your own custom
or private extensions
and use them within
the enterprise,
finally evolving into a
marketplace of connectors
where many of our
partners and customers
can actually contribute
their own extensions,
so they can be used within
the Apigee universe.
So real quick, what are
some of the key benefits
of getting the extensions?
First class self-service
extensibility
built right into the platform.
You can connect to any service.
And more importantly,
down the road,
you can build and distribute
your own service extensions.
OK, so great.
We very quickly looked at
how you can accelerate,
you know, accessing
different kind of services
and turning them into quick
APIs using extensions.
But what's underneath
those APIs?
In many cases, turns
out, enterprises
have gobs and gobs
of data and a lot
of business processes,
which really
need to be powered as APIs.
As we start to
talk about this, we
have heard from many customers
that although the API
management platform is really
awesome at curating those APIs
into some awesome experiences
for the digital experience
that they need to consume--
however, we really need to be
able to take the data, which
is sitting locked
in silos, leverage
the integration processes which
are weaved on top of that,
and really bring the entire
solution stack together,
because the reality is,
as we talked to customers,
we have integration
architects, who
need to work on working
and building those business
processes.
They need to be up
level into APIs,
so they can power
mobile, digital,
and other connected experiences.
And that's exactly
what we have done.
Some of you may have caught
up on the recent announcement
we made a couple of weeks back.
So Apigee has partnered
with Informatica,
both collectively bringing the
best of bread in leading API
management solution and
the best of breed iPaaS
solution as per leading
industry analyst together.
So we give our
customers the ability
to actually leverage these
two platforms in unison,
be more productive,
and really accelerate
their API-first strategy.
With this, I would like to
welcome Pratik on the stage.
Pratik, take it away.
PRATIK PAREKH: Thanks, Prithpal.
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
So what I'm going
to focus on is what
this partnership looks
like, where we are today,
where we are headed.
So before we get
started, let me actually
give you a quick overview of
who we are as Informatica.
Most of you probably know.
We have been in the space of
enterprise data management
for over 25 years.
And since the beginning, day
one of Informatica's foundation,
what we have done
is worked with data.
We have managed the data.
We integrate the data.
We curate the data.
We master the data.
We secure the data.
That's what the
Informatica platform--
as Informatica, what we do.
Today, Informatica
actually has--
and this is a good
slide that covers
overall the overview of
what Informatica platform
looks like.
So as you can see, there
are six different categories
that we play into--
integration, integration in
the cloud, integration on-prem,
hybrid, all of that; big
data and big data management;
data quality; data governance;
master data management;
and price data catalog;
and data security.
That experience is what we,
as Informatica and Apigee,
in this case, are trying
to nurture and help
the customers to unlock
the enterprise data assets
that you have in the enterprise
and bring it into the--
and help through your digital
transformation journey.
The area that we
will be focusing on
is integration
platform as a service.
How many of you know
what iPaaS stands for?
Integration platform
as a service
is the new integration
platform that
are mostly targeting
the cloud integration
and the hybrid integration.
Generally, the notion
there is to bring
various patterns of integration
into a managed environment.
Informatica runs as an
integration platform
as a service as a managed cloud
service that supports almost
all and supports the
multi-cloud as well as
the hybrid integration patterns.
Today, we process over 2.5
billion transactions a month.
We have over 6,000-plus,
7,000-plus customers.
We have over 100-plus
OEMs that actually--
embeddable platform underneath.
And one of the significant
characteristics
that you see in
the top right there
is 300% growth on
the API volume,
the way customers
are consuming it.
And let me go and
walk you through
as to what the
platform looks like.
So at the high level,
it's very simple.
This is what the iPaaS
from an architecture
diagram perspective.
First of all, it needs to
support an integration pattern.
Integration patterns are
currently-- as I said,
it's converging.
So there is no big distinction
between an application
integration, data
integration, IoT, big data.
All of that, you need
to now support that.
And the goal here between what
Informatica and Apigee is doing
is how do you actually expose
those integrations that you
develop in a platform
such as Informatica iPaaS
and expose that as an API?
And how you can unlock the
data assets that are behind,
running those
processes and expose
that for your digital
transformation journey?
The second thing,
which is very critical,
is the audience is actually
expanding beyond an integration
architect or an API developer.
Today, you want
to actually bring
the data in the hands of
various different users
within your enterprise-- your
business users, your admins,
and so on.
And they should be able to
do quickly data integration
and able to handle the data, and
should be in their fingertips.
The third and the key
point is that you need
to work with any sort of data.
And data is, as
you all know, could
be a structured data, which
is locked in an enterprise
database or an application.
It could be unstructured
data on your files
and log data sources.
It could be a streaming data
that is coming from various IoT
devices and so on.
And the ability to actually
work with all sorts of data
and expose that as
an API is something
that we'll be talking about.
One of the other big thing
is underlying platform
should support a lot of--
should be able to handle
this volume of data.
And that's where our
enterprise unified metadata
intelligence come into play.
This is an AI and ML
technology that actually
powers the iPaaS platform.
And finally, the
platform itself has
to be very rock solid,
scalable to actually handle
that type of volume
we were talking about.
Today, as I said, it is
growing at 300% year over year
in terms of API volume.
And we expect that
trend to continue.
In fact, we are prepared
to actually handle it,
over 1,000%.
And that's what we are
prepared to actually handle.
The key differentiator
of Informatica
is the breadth and the
depth of connectivity.
There is no single data source
out there that we cannot
connect to, even mainframe.
And we know that a
lot of organizations
today have data and business
processes locked in mainframe.
How do you actually expose
that into your digital
transformation journey?
And when we talk
about connectors,
these are rich connectors,
which are very metadata rich
and can handle various different
transformations on those data
sets.
Here, a quick example of
data stores on the big data
side, cloud applications
such as Workday, Marketo,
Conquer if you want to
actually reach to data sources
and turn that into
APIs, middleware
sources such as
TIBCO or anything
that you are talking on the
messaging infrastructure,
social applications, and so on.
What we have announced and what
we are working on with Apigee--
and this is where
we are actually
announcing the integrated
experience to you all.
And by the way, this is in beta.
First and foremost, is
the publishing capability.
So everything that you have
working with on an Informatica
environment-- and I'll give
you a quick demo on that--
you can actually expose
that into Apigee natively
and with a point-and-click UI.
Number two is to consume.
If you are an API developer and
you want to actually find out
all the various applications
and processes out
there, which is
powered by Informatica,
how do you actually extract
the value out directly
from your Apigee
Edge environment?
So that's the
subscription part of it,
and you can actually
auto-discover
in the Informatica
toolsets right
from within the
Apigee environment.
And finally, the piece that we
are working on and we are very
diligently focused on that
is how do we make these rich
connectors that we have, over
200-plus native connectors
but thousands of endpoints
that we can connect to--
how can we actually make
that available in the Apigee
environment directly
and natively
so that you can actually
unlock the power of data
and the applications
that are sitting
behind those applications and
make it available into Apigee?
So with that, let's go and
look at the first part,
the publishing of
Informatica integrations
directly into Apigee.
And I'll going into a demo.
So what I'm showing here
is a cloud user interface
of Informatica Intelligence
Cloud Services.
For this particular
demo, what you are seeing
is an integration
architect view.
And we have provisioned some
of the services of Informatica
Cloud Services to this
particular organization.
This is a subset of all the
services that Informatica Cloud
Services offer.
We have the integration hub, and
we have the big data services,
and we have data masking
services, and so on,
which are not yet visible,
because this org is powered
for the integration
architect who
is interested in the data
integration and the application
integration.
So I'm going into the
application integration,
and I'm working on an
order-processing application.
Now, this is a typical
example, where I already
have a process inside
my enterprise, which
actually takes in orders.
And it is generating
the order information,
and it is taking the order
through the lifecycle
towards order-to-cash process.
And it is doing the
order fulfillment.
It doing the order procurement.
It has to do all
of those things.
Now, imagine as this enterprise
now wants to go digital
and makes this
available to your sales
people, who are on the road.
And they are spending
a lot of cycles
right now to actually
do all this manually
after they come
back from the field.
And we want to make
this available to them
seamlessly from
within their iPhone
or from their phone
or mobile device.
So what we are trying
to look at this
is we are taking
an order processor.
Let's look at the process here.
The process is a
complex process.
It's touching number
of different endpoints.
And it is actually, as I said,
taking the order information,
and generating an order, and
then taking the process further
into the fulfillment cycle.
I want to make this available
to my API developer.
And remember, I'm playing the
role of a enterprise architect.
So this is where
the integration,
the one that I talked about,
of publishing and service
or publishing a process
to the API developer
is what I'm going to show.
So here, as you can see, we have
a natively integrated Apigee
here.
I'm going to create
this particular--
and it gives me a nice
wizard-driven approach
to actually publish this
particular process to my API
developer.
I'm going and selecting
the order processor,
and selecting the Apigee org
that I want to deploy to.
It's walking through the
steps, auto-generating the ID
for the particular process.
You can always rename it.
I want all the
interfaces to be exposed.
I have various different
security set up
that I can actually apply here.
In this case, I'm going to
just select the pass through.
I can make it available
and secure more
as well as insecure more.
In this case, I'm
going to make it
available in both given
that we are still testing
this particular process.
And I don't want to make
it available directly
in production.
I want to make it
available to the API
developer in his sandbox, so
I'm testing the test environment
here.
And that's about it.
At this point, the
order processing,
it's generating the proxy.
And it's making it available
to the API developer
to directly invoke it
from within Apigee.
There is an SSO established
between Informatica and Apigee.
So I can directly
go into this and get
into the Apigee interface here.
And as you can see,
that business process
is already available.
And the endpoint, as you
can see behind the scenes,
and the backend system is
talking to Informatica.
Let's see whether this runs.
So at this point, I'm going
to go into my Postman client.
And I'm going to run
this particular--
yeah, I found it.
Yeah.
So I send the
request over to the--
and you can see the order
information was generated.
I go back into the Apigee
console to see whether it ran.
OK, I need to
start the trace on.
And then I'll work on one
more request on Postman.
Yeah, it executed again.
OK, and let's see
the execution trace.
Yeah.
Let's look at Informatica Cloud
on the Informatica Cloud side
and see that request
came through on here.
And it shows you the process
flow, the execution path
this particular request took.
So that was a quick
demo of publishing
from within the Informatica
iPaaS to Apigee.
And we saw how seamless
this whole integration was
all the way from
actually looking
at the internal business
processes and applications
and making that available
to an API developer.
From there, the API developer
can quickly test prototype it
and then make it
available and consume it,
in this particular case,
for the mobile application
that he was building to
help out his sales team.
So we covered this
particular flow of publishing
from Informatica
to the Apigee side.
At this point, I'll hand
it back to Prithpal,
where he will go into the
other side of the integration.
PRITHPAL BHOGILL:
Thanks, Pratik.
So what you saw very
briefly out here
was how we have taken the time
to automate the user experience
for an integration
architect, who
is tasked with building
out a lot of these business
processes.
And within a few clicks, you
can push that as an API proxy
within Apigee, right?
Cuts down on a lot of the
editor-prone redundancy
and other steps that are
needed and automakers that user
experience.
All of that can be done from
within the Informatica user
interface.
So let's take a look at
the second design pattern
that we have also enabled.
And this is the deep
integration that Apigee
has done with Informatica
the other way around, right?
So in this case,
in this scenario,
really think about you
as an API developer.
As you're building your
API proxy within Apigee,
you have a requirement
to be able to reach out
to one or more Informatica
business and integration
processes, right?
So let's take a peek
at how do we really
go about enabling that user
experience without having
to leave the Apigee
user interface.
In this case, we
have actually built
on top of already
extensions framework
and built a first class
extension to the Informatica
Integration Cloud.
And in this design pattern, as
compared to the previous one,
the final request
for them ends up
with the actual backend target.
But in this case, you can
see you may have a existing
API, which routes to
your backend target,
but you can make
multiple callouts
to different kind of
integration processes.
So let's take a peek at this.
All right, so let's start here.
So I think this was working.
It's just a matter of too
many screens open out here.
The OrderProcessor-3 three was
what Pratik went us through.
Now, let's take a
quick peek at how
we would go about doing this
thing the other way around.
So I'm going to switch org here.
I'm going to gaccelerate4.
And so, again, you go
to the admin interface
here click on extensions And I
can add an extension from here.
So there is this Informatica
Integration Cloud extension
that I was talking about.
Can click on this, give it
a name, and then save it.
For the purpose of this
demo, I actually already
have configured an extension.
For the AcmeCorp,
it's the extension
which points to that specific
org within Informatica.
And in the same style of
the extension interface,
we have the credentials, which
are persisted securely for you
within this Informatica
Integration Cloud extension.
And then as an API developer,
it becomes very easy for me
to just call out that business
and integration process which
is sitting within Informatica
by using just a simple policy
step.
So here's my simple API proxy.
I could come out here, click out
on the Extension Callout policy
just in the exact same way that
I connected to the Data Loss
Prevention API.
I can select AcmeCorp.
And then I do that,
behind the scenes,
this is actually invoking the
Registry API that Informatica
has enabled as part of the
product level integration.
So this is, in real
time, introspecting
the business integration
processes, which
are published in
the Informatica org
and accessible to me using
simple design time constructs.
So I can search out
here, select the one
I want, and it's as
simple as that for me
to invoke that service.
I've already configured the
Extension Callout policy here.
And I'm trying to get
lead information back
from Informatica.
If I hovered out here real quick
within this project structure
within the demo, you
have the fetch leads
with fields business process.
Very, very simple
business process actually
goes and fetches data
out of Salesforce.
And what I do is I take that
process, call it from Apigee,
do a little bit of data
massaging in terms of the way
I want to return it, and
then I call that API.
So if I go back
out here, let's go
put this thing in trace mode.
Let's start a trace session.
I'll jump onto this out here.
I'll click on my Leads API.
Now you can see
that this Lead API
URL is different from the
business process that's
available within Informatica.
This is the actual API endpoint
that you can use and share
with your mobile apps, with
any other kinds of interface
that you're trying to
make this thing with.
This API also can
then be published
using all the Apigee
tools into a developer
portal with nice, clean
general API documentation.
And it can be
accessed and available
to power many different kinds
of connected experiences.
So this really enables--
let me run this thing
a couple times here.
So when I make a
call to this, it's
actually going over
the wire, making a call
to the Informatica
business process, which
is talking to Salesforce,
getting the data back.
We do a quick transformation
and show the data back
in the format, right?
So just imagine how the
integration architects
would work before we had
these integrations available.
It was possible, certainly.
However, it took a
lot of manual work.
In many cases,
we've seen customers
who have completely
different integration
center of excellence teams
or integration architects
and completely separate
API developer teams, right?
There's a lot of hand-holding
and manual passing
of information back and
forth, which needs to happen.
Very error prone, not as
secure, and more importantly,
it doesn't bring
out the productivity
which is required to accelerate
your API-first strategy.
So using this kind of
integration patterns,
the first one,
again, I'll recap,
which Pratik walked us
through is taking and making
the life of an integration
architect super easy
by giving you a
couple of clicks.
So right from within
the Informatica UI,
you can push these
business processes
as secure, managed API proxies.
And they can then be automated
into the API lifecycle,
so you can very confidently
share that with mobile apps,
with any other
connected experience
that you're trying to deliver.
The second thing that
we looked at was,
without leaving the
Apigee user interface,
API developers were interacting
with these kind of very
critical processes, can simply
use the extensions framework
and the first of the
extension that we
have built to the
Informatica Integration Cloud
and integrate with
those processes,
turn them into APIs
very, very rapidly.
And the last announcement that
Pratik took us through today
was that we are going to use
the exact same extensions
framework, which we have
used to enable the nine
extensions that you
saw today, and take
the rich palette of connectors
that Informatica has
to a variety of different
kinds of data sources,
all the way from
SaaS applications,
big data systems,
mainframes, and a bunch
of different on-premise sources
and turn them into connectors,
which customers can use directly
from within the Apigee user
interface.
We believe that tackles a set
of use cases for API developers
when they are not really
interested in building
a full-blown business
integration process,
but simply have
a need to connect
to different kinds of sources,
turn that into APIs very,
very quickly.
So recapping this,
today, we took you
through a journey of
how you can accelerate
your API-first strategy, unlock
the value in the enterprise
app and data sources that
you have and turn them
in to secure, manageable, and
monetizable APIs that will
power and fuel your data
transmission initiative
and your API-first strategy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]